what if Jupiter gained just a little bit
more mass during its formation period
and then ignited to become a star how
different would our solar system have
turned out when having another star in
the middle of the solar system mess with
the orbits of the planets and what we
see it from here this is what if and
here's what would happen if Jupiter
became a star Jupiter has more than
twice the mass of all the planets in the
solar system combined it doesn't have a
solid ground and is made up of the same
elements as the Sun and yet it's not a
star Jupiter doesn't have enough mass to
initiate a fusion reaction in its core
the necessary requirement to be accepted
into the star Club if only we could find
79 more Jupiter's and crash them all
into the one we have now we'd be able to
build a second star in the solar system
what would that be like a B Jupiter's
crushed together would make a star out
of the gas giant but that star would be
nothing like the Sun Jupiter would be
massive enough to become a red dwarf a
small cool hydrogen burning star and as
every red dwarf out there it wouldn't be
too bright 0.3% of the sun's luminosity
is the most light that Jupiter could
hope to spit out because Jupiter is four
times further away from us than the Sun
the earth wouldn't get much heat from it
by and large Jupiter turning into a red
dwarf wouldn't change anything for life
on earth you'd still be able to see it
from Earth a Jupiter star would appear
red and a bit brighter than the moon at
its full face would it at least have a
gravitational impact on the solar system
not as much as you might think
the former gas giant would slightly
shift the orbits of the other planets
but not enough to set them on a
collision course with one another or to
launch them out of their orbits into
outer space the only threat we'd face
would be space rocks from the asteroid
belt that Jupiter might send towards the
earth we'd need to learn how to detect
and destroy them before they could reach
our planet
other than that not much would change
for the solar system things would get a
lot more fun if Jupiter was replaced
with a sun-like star if our gas giant
became 1,000 times more massive the
solar system would go wild asteroids
would crash into planets and planets
would change their orbit of course it's
hard to predict what would happen to
earth in this gravitational mess it
could be anything from being pulled a
little too close to Jupiter star and
getting scorched to being left drifting
alone in the void of space in any case
it wouldn't be too pretty in the real
world
Jupiter is forever destined to be a
planet and that's for the best
maybe someday soon we'll get a closer
look and send a manned spacecraft
rushing inside the gas giant but that's
a story for another what-if
[Laughter]
[Music]